pas de pause sur c'est bon pour les
riverains et pour cause la scène monde
certaines promenade au bord du fleuve
sont interdites en raison de la montée
des eaux la ville de poissy à fermer le
chemin de halage qui longe l'ancien pont
de la ville
des barrières sont rajoutés pour
empêcher les riverains les plus fougueux
de braver l'interdît pour cette
habitante de poissy depuis deux ans
c'est la première fois qu'elle voit la
scène aussi haute
je suis en bordure de zone inondable
donc je croise les doigts pour que ça
soit vrai et quand je me balade souvent
avec mon chien ici j'ai vu que ça a
beaucoup bougé et je me suis dit ah
énormément de maisons en zones
inondables
donc c'est vrai que ça peut être un peu
inquiétant un autre habitant de poissy
observe l'augmentation du niveau de la
scène avec son petit-fils alors je
constate que devant les surgeons ça déjà
inondé le passage est fermé bon ça monte
pour l'instant doucement la scène et
certains de ses affluents toutefois été
placés en vigilance jaune
l'esturgeon le restaurant le plus proche
du fleuve a connu d'autres événements
marquants le directeur de
l'établissement est ici depuis 1986 on
se prépare parce que à partir du moment
où la ville commence à barricader les
bords de seine comme ça c'est que
ils ont des informations comme quoi ça
risque de monter donc on fait quand même
attention en 2016 c'est au mois de juin
donc complètement inhabituel où on a eu
une grosse grosse inondation suite au
des intempéries très nombreuses à ce
moment là en 2010 8 janvier on a eu beau
être très très grosse inondation ou là
on a été impacté on a réussi à tenir
ouvert et là est bien le but avec la
crue de la seine les piétons ont été
remplacés par les canards et les signes
eux se réjouissent et pataugent
tranquillement